here's what would happen if the
spinosaurus never went extinct the
spinosaurus lived about 95 million years
ago bigger than the T-Rex they were the
largest Predator the Nile River has ever
seen but they weren't as threatening on
land because they were pretty clumsy and
not well adapted to it if the
spinosaurus still lived in the Nile
today the crocodiles would be looking
for a new home on land humans would need
to be more aware of their surroundings
to protect themselves from the dinosaurs
Egypt's history and social Evolution
would have been very different since
ancient Egyptian culture relied on the
Nile River over the years in true human
form we probably would have started
hunting the spinosaurus for food and
fashion maybe we'd have hunted them so
much that they'd be on the brink of
Extinction would they become a protected
species or would we be happy to see them
disappear so